Speaker 1: We have seen a very interesting turn
of events over the last few days, this lawyer,
John Eastman. He's the guy who wrote the memo
to Donald Trump saying here is how Mike Pence
could overturn the election. There is a question
as to whether Eastman really believed that that
was a viable way to overturn the election or knew
it would be against the law. And this has become a
very central issue in the January 6th committee.
Eastman has now appeared on Tucker Carlson
saying that the FBI seized his phone last week.
There is video of the FBI seizing his phone last
week. And to many of us, this doesn't come as a
surprise because supposedly this other attorney,
Hirschmann, testified. The other attorney, Eric
Hirschmann, testified that he told Eastman,
you need a criminal defense attorney for what
you've done here. So we're going to go through
all of it. But for starters, here is Tucker
Carlson, very, very angry, showing the video of
Eastman having his phone seized by the FBI.
Speaker 2: Now, critically and illegally,
they seized his phone before they presented
him with a warrant. And it's on tape. Watch.
Speaker 3: So what turns out for
me when I see much more clearly.
Speaker 4: I'd like to see.
I'd like to see the morning.
I'd like to see the warrant. I'd like to see.
Unidentified: The warrant before. Take my
property.
Speaker 4:
I want you to see that they took my property
before providing me with the warrant.
Speaker 3: I'd like to read the law.
Speaker 1: Okay. Now, I have to tell you, I am.
As for due process as anyone else. If they didn't
have a warrant, I would be saying this is an
absolute travesty of justice. I spoke to a couple
of criminal defense attorneys and they said,
you know, this is really sort of a technicality.
The concern is the reason you grab the phone and
then show the warrant is he could smash the phone.
Okay. If you say you don't, here's the warrant.
Take your time to read it in a second. He grabs
the phone, throws it on the ground and crushes it
and destroys evidence. Now, would that be a crime?
Yes. But if the evidence is gone, the evidence is
gone. So criminal defense attorney attorneys told
me this is not we just show up and steal a phone.
If law enforcement shows up and steals a phone,
they have the warrant. They wanted to secure the
phone. They show the warrant. And the warrant,
of course, was for the phone and that's it.
So in I'm not a lawyer and speaking to lawyers,
they said this is this is not the travesty of
justice that Tucker Carlson is making it out
to be. So then Tucker Carlson invites Eastman,
and Eastman says that by seizing the phone,
it's also a crime because he has privileged
communications with clients on the phone.
Speaker 4: This warrant is invalid on its face.
But more importantly and and I
think this is extremely important,
the authority to seize all of my information in
modern, modern smartphones. That's access to all
my private financial records. I'm an attorney.
It's access to all my privilege communications
with nearly 100 different clients that I have
currently. All this stuff. This stuff is what
we used to call a general warrant that the British
king issued to just go rummage through somebody's
belongings to see if they could find evidence of
some crime. The very reason we have the Fourth
Amendment is to prevent that kind of abuse.
Speaker 1: It's very weird because he's the
lawyer, but he seems to misunderstand so
many things. His argument, it almost sounds
like a you can never seize the phone of a lawyer.
Lawyers use phones to communicate with clients.
If you can never sees a phone, if it has
client communications, it's almost like
you can never investigate a lawyer. I mean,
this this is the way investigations work.
And of course, the handling of the privileged
information is a different matter. But is is
this guy really this dumb? Now, any of us who
have been paying attention to this would have
anticipated that this would have happened. Here
is attorney Eric Hershman, who for the January
six committee described speaking to John Eastman
and saying what you need to do is get yourself a
criminal defense attorney for what you're doing.
Speaker 3: EASTMAN And remember why he called me
or he texted me or called me. Want to talk
with me? He said he couldn't reach others.
And he started to ask me about something dealing
with Georgia and preserving something potentially
for appeal. And. I said to him, Are you
out of your f ing mind? I said. I said,
I only want to hear two words coming out of
your mouth. For now on. Orderly transition.
No screams that I don't want to hear any other f
ing words coming out of your mouth no matter what,
other than orderly transition. Repeat those
words to me and I feel 97 eventually. You
said orderly transition. I said, Good, John. Now
I'm going to give you the best free legal advice
you're ever getting in your life. Get a great F in
criminal defense lawyer. You're going to need it.
Speaker 1: Right. So we all, of course, have
been expecting this to happen. And indeed,
now it did. Now here's the cherry on top. Tucker
Carlson, you know, just lionizing this guy who
came up with an illegal way to try to prevent
Joe Biden from becoming president. Tucker says
if you're not a Biden voter, you should regularly
be purging your phone of all of your text messages
and emails because they could be coming for you.
Speaker 4: The very reason we have the Fourth
Amendment is to prevent that kind of abuse.
And yet that's what they're doing here.
Speaker 2: And it's just another reminder to
anyone who didn't vote for Joe Biden to raise your
texts and emails every single day. And that is the
sincere piece of advice I hope everyone follows,
but they haven't charged with a crime. They've
given you no evidence that they're going to
charge you with a crime, but they treat you like
a drug kingpin or a rapist and seize your phone.
Speaker 1: Is this legal?
Speaker 4: I don't think so.
Speaker 1: And it's it it appears that it is
actually illegal. So there's Tucker Carlson
recommending clear your phone of all texts and
emails every day. If you didn't vote for Joe
Biden, these people live in a fantasy
world. But it is a dangerous fantasy world
where their delusions have real
world impact. We expect that at